[Musique]
le département de La Réunion a décidé de
favoriser la mobilité et l'insertion
professionnelle de jeunes réunionnés et
de seniors qualifiés bénéficiire du RSA
dans la zone Océan Indien le Conseil
départemental apporte ainsi une
contribution significative à travers le
recrutement et la mise à disposition de
personnes qualifiées au profit de pays
et de structure de la Francophonie de la
zone
il s'agit d'un contrat d'insertion
destiné aux personnes de plus de 25 ans
bénéficiaires du RSA en recherche
d'emploi la mission est d'une durée de 1
an renouvelable une fois nous avons pu
rencontrer six d'entre eux à quelques
jours du départ je suis Miss donc par le
Conseil Général donc pour prendre la
direction de l'Alliance française anoui
à Madagascar alors moi je vais être
consultante au SAL nations en fait dans
un premier temps je vais faire le
diagnostic de la place du français au
sein des médias que ce soit au niveau de
la radio de la télévision et du journal
et dans un deuxième temps en fait former
les journalistes séchelllois en langue
française voilà alors je vais être
assistante d'éducation en langue
française au séchel donc normalement je
suis rattachée à un collège je ne sais
pas encore exactement lequel et un
professeur référent puisque je suis
censée l'aider et et dans
l'apprentissage des élèves dans la
langue française en fait en fait il
s'agit d'un projet de renforce du
français en Tanzanie donc de la langue
française c'est un projet à l'échelle
nationale dans lequel je suis impliqué
en tant que coordonnatrice je vais être
chargée de coordination culturelle du
coup pour l'Alliance française de port
ellisabeth et je je serai chargé de la
communication aussi euh donc je seraiis
coordonnateur de projet à l'Alliance
française de céchel donc d'après ce
qu'on m'a dit ce serait en tant que une
sorte de coordination des projets
pédagogiques qui tourne autour du du
DELF et du DALF ce sont des
certifications en langue française en
fait une véritable expérience
professionnelle et une seconde chance
pour ces personnes
qualifiées en fait pour moi
personnellement c'est une chance parce
que c'est non seulement c'est une
mission en cours en plus c'est une
réinsertion au sens propr du terme pour
moi et puis il faut dire que c'est une
chance aussi de de bénéficier de la
mobilité c'est toujours ement personnel
bah c'est une chance parce qu'on peut se
faire une expérience à l'étranger on
peut rencontrer une nouvelle culture
rencontrer un nouveau pays qui est juste
à côté de la Réunion et c'est vraiment
et une expérience en anglais en plus
donc c'est vraiment génial quoi c'est
une chance parce que de d'être trop
diplômé à la Réunion c'est compliqué de
s'intégrer donc de s'expatrier avec son
expertise dans la zone indien c'est
peut-être un bon moyen de revenir ou de
devenir un expert de la zone à quelques
jours our du départ l'excitation a gagné
chacun d'entre eux avec pour certains
tout de même quelques
appréhensions il y a une appréhension
dans le sens où déjà je n'ai jamais été
enuie mais j'ai eu l'occasion parce que
j'ai eu toute mon enfance à Madagascar
donc c'est un petit peu un retour aux
sources je suis une éternelle partie ça
fait 15 ans que je fais le tour du monde
et je travaille dans des pays différents
donc pour moi c'est presque c'est une
super chance de pouvoir continuer sur
cette route là excité mais en même temps
un peu
sur la défensive on va dire ou dans dans
le sens où ben on sait pas exactement
sur ce qu'on va avoir quoi c'est ça en
fait on a des pistes parce qu'on a une
formation juste avant donc on se doute
de ce qu'on va devoir faire et comment
on va devoir faire mais comme on a
jamais fait ça exactement et ben ça va
être une grande découverte mais je suis
tout excitée je suis je suis pressée je
suis super contente de partir ça va
j'apprendre pas trop je dirais
euh
serein mais quand même avec quelques
réserves par rapport à l'endroit déjà
c'est un endroit que j'ai jamais visiter
donc là c'est un peu l'aventure pour moi
en tout
[Musique]
cas